j'ai été nommé co rapporteur d'une
mission flash sur la parité dans les
communes de moins de 1000 habitants et
dans les exécutifs communautaire
aujourd'hui on pourrait penser que la
parité s'applique dans tous les scrutins
eh bien non dans les communes de moins
de 1000 habitants vous n'avez pas
d'obligation de parité que les communes
de moins de 1000 habitants
c'est la majorité des communes est donc
aujourd'hui on a quand même 74 % des
communes dans lesquelles ne s'appelle la
parité ne s'applique pas pour les
législatives
il y a une obligation de parité pour les
conseils départementaux on a un binôme
hommes femmes dans les conseils
régionaux on a des listes paritaires
au sénat aussi on a des listes
paritaires et finalement dans tous les
scrutins
vous avez la parité sauf dans les
communes de moins de 1000 habitants
alors pourquoi est ce que c'est
important de mettre en place la parité
dans les communes de moins de 1000
habitants
déjà parce que c'est une demande des
associations d'élus locaux qu'ils disent
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'ils auraient
deux types de communes les communes où
on à la parité et les communes où on n'a
pas la parité
et puis on peut se poser la question
aussi de façon générale pourquoi est ce
que il faut mettre en place la parité
alors c'est des débats qui ont eu lieu
comme vous le savez peut-être et qui se
sont mis en place dans les années 2000
et en fait maintenant dans notre
constitution à l'article 1er il est
indiqué que la loi favorise l'égal accès
des hommes et des femmes au scrutin donc
c'est une application de la constitution
aujourd'hui il ya un consensus tous les
partis politiques sont pour la parité
donc voilà la parité elle a fait son
chemin depuis les années 2000 on est en
la parité a fait son chemin tout le
monde est d'accord par contre là où
où on voyait encore des difficultés
c'est comment on la met en place donc je
rentrerai pas dans les détails mais
c'est ce sur quoi on va travailler dans
la mission flash
certains nous disent mais on trouve pas
de femme alors moi je m'étonne
parce que même dans les villages j'en ai
dans ma circonscription de 50 habitants
et bien il ya autant d'hommes que de
femmes
donc si dans un village il ya autant
d'hommes que de femmes à fort sur l'île
peut y avoir dans un conseil municipal
autant d'hommes que de femmes